immer mehr isis mitglieder fliehen aus
nord syrien nach deutschland bei mir im
studio ist jetzt wünscht ritze
vielleicht kannst du uns da ein bisschen
mehr zu sagen wer kommt nach deutschland
und woher genau was wir haben ja knapp
etwas über 1000 deutsche die in den
letzten jahren sich nach irak und syrien
abgesetzt haben dorthin gereist sind
großteils herrschaftsgebiet des cs viele
sind zurückgekehrt
unmittelbar nachdem sie eingereist sind
oder kurz danach einige allerdings sind
in gefangenschaft geraten vor allem
nachdem der es quasi militärisch besiegt
wurde in kurdische gefangenschaft
geraten der in die fänge dieser
kurdischen miliz und die frauen und
kinder werden in sogenannten camps in
flüchtlingscamps bewacht werden dort
überwacht allerdings hat deutschland wie
viele andere staaten bislang seine
staatsbürger die gefangenen deutschen
dort nicht zurück geholt was dazu führt
dass viele dieser frauen die dort
inhaftiert sind irgendwann auf eigene
faust
ja es sich aus diesen camps geschmuggelt
haben schmuggler bezahlt haben teilweise
mit ihren kindern unter gefährlichen
wegen und dann nach deutschland
zurückkommen das problem was dann
dadurch aufgeworfen wird ist natürlich
zum einen dass dann ein bisschen
unkontrollierte rückkehr ist weil
natürlich niemand genau weiß wer kommt
dann wann wo wie zurück mit welchen
absichten und dergleichen
deswegen gab es schon vor zwei drei
jahren als sich dieses problem andeutete
dass die forderung von von
sicherheitsexperten die leute
kontrolliert nach deutschland
zurückzuholen wenn sie deutsche
staatsbürger sind genau die gefangenen
camps das ist ja gerade angesprochen
vorstellen also ich war ja auch mehrfach
dort das sind einerseits
flüchtlingslager für binnenvertriebene
in syrien dem irak isi bilde da aus dem
aus dem hauptteil von kemper holding dem
größten dieser camps daneben 60.000
menschen knapp der großteil davon sind
syrer und iraker binnenvertriebene und
dann gibt es aber einen separaten
bereich in dem in dem ausländischer es
mitglieder die entweder geflohen sind
vom ds oder gefangen genommen wurden von
den kunden dann in diesen bereich
gesteckt werden und wir wollen jetzt
sprechen mit einer deutschen die vor
kurzem aus einem solchen kern geflohen
ist aber noch nicht wieder zurück in
deutschland ist
haben kannst mich hören ja ich kann es
ja sehr gut genau
kannst du uns einmal beschreiben du
warst ja auch lange in diesem camp dass
wir gerade gesehen haben ein camper
inhaftiert kannst du uns ein bisschen
die die lage dort beschreiben wie das
leben dort war ja ich hab gerade die
live bilder gesehen das war wieder sehr
schockierend
kein schöner anblick war sehr hart war
nicht leicht auch wie meine kinder jetzt
wenn man dort kein geld hat dann muss
man sich eigentlich aus verhungern
einstellen quasi du lebst in zelten 50
grad hitze mit skorpione schlangen die
tiere und die umwelt ist jetzt auch sehr
gefährlich zeit auch ein kriegsgebiet wo
jeder zeit wo die lage halt auch nicht
sicher als du liebst hat permanent 24
stunden mit angst aber die menschen die
mit dir auch drin im camp sind es gibt
sie auch noch relativ radikale
angestellte frauen die es zum beispiel
das nicht passt wie du dich bedeckt was
du anziehst was du hörst ob du raus oder
nicht halt diese radikalen einstellungen
ja die kinder leiden am meisten darunter
da die kinder halt das was sie sehen das
lernen die die wachsen so auf je länger
die dort sind desto mehr prägt sich das
in deren köpfen ein
ich hatte glück meine kinder noch jungen
wir haben das jetzt alles sehr gut
verarbeitet und sind halt
weg darüber quasi für mich wahrheit über
jahre dort ich habe es auch raus
geschafft ich musste mich auch raus
schmuggeln lassen war sehr gefährlich es
ging um wochen ist ging um leben und tod
eine bekannte von mir ist über eine mine
gelaufen sie hat ihren sohn verloren
zweieinhalb monate war der sohn auf
einer anderen seite
und sie war selber in ärztlicher
behandlung dann im gefängnis dann wurde
sie wieder zurück ins camp gebracht dann
ist sie wieder denselben weg gegangen
wieder und irgendwann mal kamen sie dann
zu ihrem sohn aber der summe halt auch
verletzt durch die mine
man geht halt so einige risiken ein für
das man fehler aus naivität dahingehend
viele durch diese einstellung was man
dort erlebt es kann also schlimmer
horrorfilm denke ich also und ich bin
wer dorthin zu gehen das bisschen
schwierig jetzt für mich ja dass du hast
ja auch gerade schon beschrieben dass
das da sozusagen immer noch frauen sind
die diese ideologie in sich tragen was
was passiert wenn diese frauen dann wenn
du mich mit denen auseinandergesetzt hat
oder wenn wenn sie merken dass das du
dich quasi vorerst abgewendet hast wie
reagieren die daraufhin den kampf was
auch schon passiert ist natürlich ich
war halt in dem lager und das wird in
mehreren teilen aufgeschnitten zum
beispiel im vorderen teil gesehen wie
jetzt gerade sehen der durch die straße
lang fährt das ist die außenseite auf
der straße auf der anderen seite
gegenüber ist halt die bg das sind erst
so die kontrollierten camps von der epg
mit der kamera das hat die krasse es
leute wie zum beispiel aus barfuß das
ist der letzte standpunkt aus dem es die
frauen dort haben natürlich noch eine
heftigere ideologie weil sie es halt
dort so lange ausgehalten haben oder das
hat sich so eingebrannt haben im kopf
also sehr vergiftet in dem was sie
denken
was gefährlich jetzt ist zum beispiel
wenn eine frau den schwarzen gewand
trägt wenn sie jetzt etwas buntes trägt
wenn sie keine handschuhe trägt wenn sie
ihre augen offen lässt wenn sie ihr
gesicht öffnet was die untereinander
nicht akzeptieren jetzt zum beispiel
wenn ich schätze nicht passend gekleidet
habe wie sie oder wenn meine kinder
halten ja noch klein sich so angezogen
haben wie sie wollen die attackieren
dann einen schon auch mit schlägen und
drohen die das zelt abzubrennen und
deswegen bist du hast du dich ja dann
auch zur flucht entschieden die relativ
gefährlich weil du bist doch nicht nach
deutschland zurückgekehrt nur ganz kurz
noch glaubst du dass mehrere von den
deutschen genau dort inhaftiert sind
dass sie dann auch denselben weg gehen
werden wenn sie nicht zurückgeholt
werden nicht gehen werden es gibt schon
viele die unterwegs sind viele sich
nicht verstecken viele die schon
eingereist sind viele sich in anderen
ländern quasi aufhalten
du musst auch so bedenken dass nicht
alle radikal sind aber auch nicht alle
nicht also es gibt auch gefährliche
frauen und männer die das schaffen auch
raus zu kommen ja und für die für die
staatssicherheit wäre es natürlich
besser sie kontrolliert zurück zu holen
weil alles bald kontrolliert ist du
weißt okay ich hab dir jetzt rausgeholt
dies in unseren handys dann kommt dann
ins gefängnis oder vor gericht aber so
wenn jemand sich jetzt bei familie unter
komplex oder jetzt einem anderen land
oder im schenken bereich ist schon
gefährlich auch für die nachbarstaaten
oder halt will die stadt bonn gefahren
hat danke danke dafür
danke für diese einblicke